[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar detection of sars kovi ii
antibodies using an innovative approach
dried blood spots offer the possibility
of home-based self-collection
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diasoren to learn more visit
diazorn.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr carmen l charlton phd
board certified clinical microbiologist
clinical director diocerine
dr charlton you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you very much for having me
today i'm excited to talk to you about
what we've been doing with dry blood
spots and sars kobe 2 antibodies
so i'll
do a little bit of background for myself
first
i'm a board-certified clinical
microbiologist and i've been working in
public health for nearly 10 years now
uh
my
kind of domain we do about 2 million
tests per year to give you an idea of
what we test is environmental water
testing enteric disease things like
outbreak investigations we also do
immunity testing including sars kobe 2
antibodies
mycobacteriology mycology and
parasitology we also look at transplant
virology zoonotic diseases
and emerging pathogen testing so we have
a very wide base of different tests that
we do at public health and
my program lead particularly is i look
at hiv hepatitis prenatal screening and
most recently copic serology
i am an associate professor at the
university of alberta in the department
of laboratory medicine and pathology and
clinical director at test and travel
and i work with a
number of different research institutes
including the li kashing institute for
virology
and i'm a member of the canadian
national covet serology working group
and i'll touch a little bit on that work
later on in the presentation as well
okay as we're all familiar with source
code b2 is the virus that causes coping
19 infection and here we can see an
illustrated version of what the virus
looks like you have the spike protein in
green which is associated with entry
into the cell there's also
the membrane proteins which are around
the edges
you can see the nucleocapsid and the
nucleocapsid is going to be important
when we talk a little bit more about
antibodies antibody generation a little
bit later on and then interior to the
virus is the rna which is detected by
pcr mechanisms
so what we'll be looking at for sars
cov2 serology is really the spike
protein primarily and the spike protein
is responsible for binding to the ace2
receptor on cells so in your body cells
and this is going to be the angiotensin
converting enzyme to
and when those two make contact it
basically allows internalization of the
virus and then infection
what we want with an immune response are
neutralizing antibodies to prevent that
interaction between the ac2 receptor and
the spike protein and when you have
neutralizing antibodies they're able to
prevent basically that spike protein
from touching the receptor and therefore
the virus is never internalized and you
don't have infection
so to look at the spec protein a little
bit
closer um it is actually the target for
many of the serological assays which
makes sense because you want to know if
your body is making antibodies to that
spike subunit
and the targets for serological assays
will look at either the whole spike
protein so the spike as well as that
c-terminal
domain complex with the receptor binding
domain
here labeled rbd
as well as the
n-terminal domain so those kind of
globular tops on the spike and some
assays will look at just the partial
spikes so just the very top part
and some will look at just that receptor
binding domain and the receptor binding
domain is really important for making
contact with that ac2
receptor and is really where it actually
binds and so many of the neutralizing
antibodies that we
see are targeted towards that receptor
binding domain because they were they're
the best at preventing that interaction
between the spike and the ace ii
so for coping 19 serology really what
we're doing is we're detecting
antibodies that are specific to the
virus so stars cov2
in the blood so serum or plasma
and there's really a limited role of
cova-19
diagnosis for acute infection with
serology and this is really because it
takes time for the antibodies to develop
so it takes 7 to 14 days after symptom
onset to develop a reliable and
measurable antibody response
and antibodies may not be detected at
all especially in mild or asymptomatic
cases
and we're still learning about what role
and immunity and longevity of protection
the antibodies actually have
um compared to things like cell mediated
immunity and what role antibodies play
in that
back and forth
so if we looked at this pictorially we
can see that over time if you are
exposed um
pre-symptom onset so that dashed
vertical line is
your
time that you would start to
elicit symptoms
so before that is when you're exposed to
the virus and you can see that it's
probably detection is unlikely by most
most mechanisms
the blue line that you start to see
coming up first is a nasopharyngeal swab
pcr and that's probably the first thing
that we detect post symptom onset and
maybe maybe a day before symptom onsite
you can detect it as well
that rises pretty sharply which
increases the chances of detection and
then falls by about week four to a
fairly low level baseline
and although we know that we can detect
pcr up to 30 or more days post infection
or post-symptom onset the likelihood of
detecting pcr is really in that first
two and maybe three weeks post-symptom
onset
serology on the other hand
takes a little bit of a lag to start
being able to be detected
so between
two to three weeks and probably greater
than 21 days is really when you have a
strong
measurable antibody response
um igm and igg typically come up
concomitantly with one another early in
infection and then igm then will wane
which is the purple dotted line
and the igg will be maintained longer
which is the green dotted line
interestingly uh the yellow line there
is stool pcr and this one it comes into
roles when you're looking at wastewater
responses
in population-based studies so because
the chronovirus can be detected in stool
you can then use wastewater to look at
a possible re-emergence of when the
virus is coming up
so how well can these antibodies really
be detected by commercial assays well
we very early in the pandemic um had
the opportunity to examine a number of
commercial assays as well as point of
care devices to see how well they can
detect these antibodies and i know the
writing is small but basically what i
want you to see is a take home is that
none of the assays are very good
pre two weeks uh post and post pcr
diagnosis so all of these were pcr
positive and then later we drew serum on
the individuals
and you can see that at 0 to 14 days
post pcr diagnosis
the athletes are pretty bad at detecting
antibodies and this isn't really
a detriment to the assay but more of how
your
body actually makes antibodies so
there's just not a lot of antibody
production in that time point
between 15 and 21 days the assays do get
better um the sensitivities go up quite
a bit more but really after 21 days is
when the majority of assays are reliably
detecting high levels of antibodies and
showing that there is at least an igg or
igm response
so early in the pandemic and now we
still get lots of questions about
serology um
people ask what does a positive serology
mean
well when you look at the context of
what i've just shown you it can either
mean that you've had past infection or
vaccination
or it could be a false positive on the
assay
um
does a positive mean i'm immune well
that that is kind of the million dollar
question right now and is something that
we know
not necessarily is true so if you have
antibodies it doesn't necessarily mean
that you are immune from infection and a
lot of work is going into this right now
to see if there is
a cut off value
something that we would use for
say rubella or measles or mom something
that would say you're protected or
you're susceptible to infection so a lot
of work is going into this right now
uh one thing that physicians ask quite a
lot is can i order serology to diagnose
acute
infection and the answer to this is no
and just how the antibody response comes
you're not going to reliably detect
these up to three weeks and by then you
hopefully are done with your infection
some physicians ask if their patient was
positive can they use serology to track
infection and right now the answer for
that is no
a lot of assays have now come out with
quantitative measures um but we haven't
really been using this as a way to track
infection
physicians also ask can i use serology
for retrospective diagnoses and we have
allowed this in certain small situations
like miss c and children
um to see if they haven't had a positive
pcr then we can actually say that they
have been exposed to covet using a
nucleocapsid antibody but the
utility of this is quite small
and other questions that physicians will
ask is their patient had a negative
cover 19 pcr but they still have
symptoms can they use serology to
diagnose infection and
well typically true i think clinically
is less valuable unless you are looking
at something like a misty condition
so putting that all together where do we
really go from here so we know that we
have assays that can detect antibodies
about three weeks out
um but what does that mean so i thought
i'd share a little bit about my
experience during covet
and
so
i'm located uh in the province of
alberta in canada in that that red boxed
province so we're
in edmonton which is fairly far north
and we have a provincial population of
about 4.5 million people
and what we really wanted to know is
what is the true prevalence of cova 19
in our province we were doing
wide-ranged pcr testing but we wanted to
know
are people not coming in for testing or
are we missing people
and so really we wanted to highlight how
many people are we being are being
missed for current not testing our
nucleic acid testing policies
so what we did um is we took a residual
serum approach
and we wanted to see what was happening
in the first two waves so at the time
the uh
the peak in may of 2020 was really high
for what we thought was high um and it
turns out that's
just the tip of the iceberg but
basically our first coveted uh case was
seen in march of 2020
and from then we started to see quite a
bit of a peak uh so we started with our
first restrictions in march uh 15th of
2020 and we saw an increase in our
coveted cases
the dark line
the dark black line is our seven day
trend average for pcr positives and then
the orange bars are the number the daily
number of pcr positive cases
and so what we did for a residual steros
survey is that
from five different sites uh in rural
and to metropolitan areas we collected
specimens
uh during the gray bars so each of those
vertical gray bars is a time that we
collected
uh five days worth of specimens
essentially from those areas to try to
get a better idea what was happening in
our population
and so you can see that we
missed the first wave but we did
track across the second wave
to look for antibody positivity
and what we found was that age groups
early on in the pandemic showed
different prevalence levels so one thing
that was really interesting to us is the
top graph for zero to nine years because
we essentially had very few or no
pcr positives in this age range and yet
our prevalence levels by antibody were
quite high and so this was one of the
first indications that we were seeing a
lot of asymptomatic
infection in our kids
and in the older age ranges the
prevalence for pcr especially for um 80
plus where we were doing high levels of
pcr testing were very concordant with
what we were seeing with the pcr so we
weren't really missing very many cases
by testing by pcr in those age
categories but we were definitely
missing cases in the zero to nine year
category
this graph um
combines our
knowledge of the nucleic acid testing to
serology testing so basically once there
was a pcr positive that was our time
zero and then along the bottom axis is
the weeks from that first pcr
so we knew that um
when the serologies were drawn
they
how how much time they were out from
that first pcr and we can see that the
antibodies really were able to still be
detected 40 weeks out from infection and
the drop by 40 weeks is just the number
of samples we had that far out from pcr
not necessarily the number of them that
we were being detected
and so we can still see that the igg
positives uh the black bars are still
positive in that 40-week range um but we
are still seeing some negatives or we're
seeing a higher proportion of negatives
at that
point time point
the other thing that's interesting is
that we're seeing a lot of negatives
very early on an infection which really
backs up what we saw earlier of the
assays not being able to detect
antibodies before three weeks
post-infection
so when can serology really be useful
well i think the main thing is really
for these seroprevalent studies i think
they give a really good idea of what's
happening in your population and it also
can help public health measures um to
put in
you know maybe
your antibody levels are declining maybe
that might be a better time for
vaccination
i think a clinical indication that still
remains helpful for serology is misc
which is the multi-inflammatory syndrome
in children
occasionally when you see unusual
neurologic or
thrombocytopenic events or embolic
events excuse me
covalent serology can also help there
and things like covatos that other
viruses can cause too but maybe you
don't have a pcr diagnosis on file you
can use serology to help diagnose for
those ones as well but i think the main
thing for serology is really these sarah
prevalent studies to look at a
population-based sampling rather than
individual clinical cases
so i was able to
work with the
canadian immunity task force serology
working group and
very early in the pandemic we were kind
of tasked to
guide recommendations for canada of how
we should be using these serological
tasks
and so we
essentially came together
one designate per province at least
to put together how we should structure
these algorithms for testing who should
be tested what recommendations we should
make and this is really um
because serology has limited diagnostic
capacity for acute infection
and its role in providing that
population-based information on
positivity rates and informing those
evidence-based decisions for public
health recommendations was really
increasing at the time
so because vaccines were also coming out
at the same time there was this
increasing pressure on clinical labs to
provide antibody screening and
result interpretation for vaccinated and
non-vaccinated individuals
what was available by the assays was by
different companies for their assays was
changing quite rapidly and so basically
we had put together a guidance on how to
verify these commercial assays and then
choose appropriate testing algorith
algorithms based on the local population
so
i've talked about these different
residual studies
and how they can really help for public
health managers but
one thing that we very quickly
identified is
are all populations represented and
unfortunately the answer to this is no
um even within our residual study and so
when we look at our residual study we
tested
basically the five rural sites and two
metro sites so grand prairie is one of
our rural sites as well as lethbridge
medicine hat and red deer
calgary and edmonton being our
metropolitan areas but you can see
there's a huge section of alberta in
gray which is termed rural so it's
further away from these testing centers
and while we use grand prairie for
example as a catchment area
for more rural areas if somebody is
living in northern alberta it can take
them hours and hours to get
to drive to grand prairie for a blood
collection and so we are likely missing
a fairly significant portion of our
population because they don't have as
direct access to care or they're not in
the catchment areas for our more rural
sites that we used in the residual zero
survey
and when we put all these data together
we saw very quickly that our rural sites
which is the gray bar on the very bottom
of all of these
was
quickly increasing so in june
the rural positivity was less than five
percent
less than one percent actually uh in
september it's went up to about two
point five percent and then in november
it also increased to about three percent
and this is um
much higher cereal prevalence than the
urban cities compared to
the amount of representation that we
were getting in them
and so there was likely a lot more
positivity in the rural areas than what
we were picking up just based on how we
were collecting samples
but underserved populations are really
hard to reach so a lot of serology
studies including ours
are performed on individuals with easy
access to care
those residual
specimens that we got were from other
testing for people who were directly
accessing care and so if you had any
barriers to care if you were in a rural
population a marginalized population or
another barrier to care you're not going
to be included in this
sarah prevalence survey
so to include these populations you
really need an easy to use collection
method
and preferably one that doesn't really
need a trained health care provider to
implement because we already know the
challenges of getting out to these rural
sites and getting specimens collected
from the rural sites
so i guess there's a couple different
options one would be to allow
point-of-care serology testing to those
areas and we were able to evaluate a
number of different point-of-care assays
when they first came out in early 2020
and
just like the larger commercial assays
they were very poor at detecting
antibodies
before three weeks of infection but post
three weeks they're actually pretty good
and if you combine their igm and igg
scores a lot of them had a sensitivity
of a hundred percent for the samples
that we tested
so this would be a possibility
um the challenge with these ones is
then training people to do them um
getting you know either a clio wave test
to get into those areas or extending
your umbrella to
more rural providers to do it so it's a
lot more challenging to get the point of
care serology testing out
and then the other option is to use a
dried blood spot so samples can be
collected at home
the results are more standardized
because the tests themselves are
actually performed in the laboratory
and the sample collection is relatively
easy
um because you can ship dried blood
spots through regular mail and they're
considered non-infectious that makes an
easy transport system
and the cost is way lower low excuse way
lower than if you use phlebotomy
so i'll focus on a study that was done
across canada
and this was performed by the national
lab where they used
10 commercial and two in-house developed
tests to assess
sars kobe 2 antibody detection and what
they did is they took 10 known positives
and 10 known negative
samples and they reconstituted it with
red blood cells to create the dried
blood spots
they then ship those dried blood spots
to different labs in canada
and those different labs perform the
testing and set the data back to the
national microbiology lab to analyze
so the a couple of them were really good
so the euro immune the alexis spike and
the gsp delphia had 100 sensitivity
specificity positive predictive value
and negative predictive value so they
actually performed very well
um some of the larger
commercial assays like the liaison the
architect and the siemens the cove to
cove2g assay
they had a pretty good specificity and
positive predictive value but
very low sensitivity so less than 20
um and less than 55 for the negative
predictive value
now there is a caveat for this study
that they say that they did actually not
perform any optimization they basically
just took a protocol
use that same protocol for all of the
different assays
and to see how they would perform
so this is a bit of a busy slide but i
just wanted to show how the acid is
compared to one another so you can see
um in the second column it has dbs
punches so that's basically the amount
of specimen that they were putting into
their dilutions um the uramune and the
platelet
have two punches
and these are plate-based assays so they
would require less input of volume
whereas the liaison the cena siemens the
roche
the abbott etc all needed four punches
to really get
a higher level of specificity and
positive predictive value
but unfortunately the liaison at 10
percent and the architect at 20
sensitivity
really were not performing well
in addition to the siemens was also at
10
so it seems like the larger assays or
the commercial base assays that require
a larger volume input were a little bit
unfairly um
degraded in their sensitivity probably
because there was a higher dilution
factor even though you're using four
punches for them
just because you have a dead volume in
these instruments
and so i think
dbs is really
an okay sample type to use you just have
to optimize your instruments
so the other question that we had is
really
how good is at home collection for these
dried blood spots
there was a paper that was published um
fairly recently in 2022 by mess at all
and they looked at um at home collection
of dry blood spots specifically for um
coveted antibodies and basically what
they would do is they would send this
card um to their volunteers who were
participating in the study they would
then spot five spots uh let it dry pop
it in a biohazard bag and then they
would mail it to the lab once it's in
the lab the lab would punch out um
a hole
they would then dilute that punch and
then they would test it on the
instrument
so what they found is that for their
essay they were looking at um for their
punches uh pcr based assay and they
actually found that uh both the negative
predictive value the positive predictive
value were very good and the sensitivity
was also
quite good with the
pcr based diagnostics
and they did a review of a bunch of
different other studies as well
including venous plasma antibody
measurements
and when you compare um an at-home
collection versus a healthcare provided
collection they were essentially
equivalent in their ability to detect
the antibodies and so i think this at
home collection does bring
testing more direct to the patient
because they can do it at home it's
equivalent to a healthcare provider
doing the testing and they can send it
in the mail something that maybe they
would have to drive two or three hours
in our case for
people living very
really remote
to a phlebotomy center so they don't
have to go to the phlebotomy center now
and can just mail in their dry blood
spots
so we wanted to tackle um the problem of
having those very reduced sensitivities
in the higher higher volume commercial
based assays and so what we wanted to do
is an optimization of dried blood spuds
on the liaison the diasporin instrument
so we looked at two different things we
did contrived blood spots just like they
did in the national microbiology
laboratory study um
and what we did is fairly similar to
what they had is that we had residual
serum and plasma samples that we had
previously tested for
sarcobi2 antibodies so we knew what the
results should be
and we mix those one-to-one with red
blood cells to essentially recreate a
whole blood scenario
we took 75 microliters of that and we
spotted onto five different spots on our
dried blood spot
and we allowed those cars to dry for two
hours in a bio safety hood and then we
stored them at room temperature for
seven days in a biohazard bag with a
desiccant
now i think that's really important that
we
left them out for seven days because we
wanted to test
if those cards are going to be robust
enough to make it through the mail
system
and sometimes from very rural sites it
takes a long time for even canada posts
to get to
the laboratory so we want to make sure
that those cards could sit at room
temperature at least and still be stable
and give us good results
so we have results up to uh now three
weeks out and they're
essentially equivalent to the seven days
so we know that
the
dried blood spots at room temperature
are very robust and can be left out for
a long period of time
the other thing that we wanted to look
at is whole blood dried blood spot um
because this is really the sample type
that we would actually be getting it's
just a harder sample type to get because
you need volunteers to donate both blood
and
a dry blood spot at the same time to
really make a good evaluation
so we did find those volunteers and they
donated blood
so we did a paired dried blood spot as
well as a serum for testing
so the whole blood was spotted onto the
dried blood spot um prior to spinning
the tube where we collected the serum
and then we stored the serum samples at
four degrees until they were tested and
the dried blood spot samples were again
just like in the contrived blood spots
were allowed to dry in the bio safety
cabinet and then we stored them for at
least seven days prior to testing
so a few things that we did for
optimization we took 10 or 15 rather of
our
contrived dried blood spot samples to
use in the optimization so 10 positives
and 5 negatives
and we varied our incubation times we
varied our shaking times so we looked at
30 minutes 45 minutes an hour and we
also looked at the volume of sample
diluent so
we looked at 200 microliters with two
spots 300 with two spots 600 with four
and a thousand with four spots
and we also looked at the ways to
extract the dried blood spots from the
sample
so one one way we used we cut up the
strips
with scissors
and put them into the tube and the other
way which the techs vastly preferred was
that you put the dried blood spot paper
over the top of your tube that you're
using and then you use a one mil pipette
just to pop the whole dried blood spot
into the tube
that
is easier because you just use a
disposable tip and you can throw it away
you don't have to clean the scissors in
between and it's a one step action
rather than
very laboriously sniffing up that dried
blood spot into the tube
so we quickly found out that there was a
trade-off in sensitivity when you had
higher volumes but it was very difficult
to
remove small volumes from the filter
paper because it would just suck up the
small volumes and you'd have to
kind of use the side of your pipette to
try to wring out the volume from the
filter paper
so
we did run into a few tr problems
getting that diluent out and so we tried
centrifuging at first but the filter
paper is very absorptive and it would
just reconstitute or absorb the
liquid essentially before you could get
it out of the centrifuge and so you're
basically wringing it out with the side
of pipette tip which the text did not
really like but one thing that did
really work for us is that we used um
kyjan spin columns and we put the dried
blood spots on the top and spun them
down and then the deli one was there so
that that actually worked even with
lower levels of diluent that was
initially added
so our validation design of contrived
blood dried blood samples we had 30 high
positives 10 mid-range positives and 10
low positives
and we had 50 samples so what we found
was that
these are the 30 high positive samples
and
the red which you can't really see very
often is this
280 which is the maximum amount
that we that i used in this um study
without the auto dilution on the
diaphragm so this is 20 80
binding
antibody units per ml and that's going
to be the maximum
that we see and i kind of
moved all the other assays to the same
level just so you can kind of see a
better comparison
so the dsrn serum of the contrad blood
spots is basically at the max for all of
these samples
and the blue is the or sorry the serum
is at the max the blue is the dry blood
spot which you can see kind of drops
uh on a few of them but it's really over
1300 for all of them
the other two colors that you see on
here are the abbott
receptor binding domain so it's a little
bit lower but again the
diosaurin is a trimeric assay so it's
looking at three different components of
the spike protein whereas the abbot is
the receptor binding domain
and then finally in yellow is the gen
script which is looking for neutralizing
antibodies so just as a reminder
um again the diasporin assay you have
the three antibodies that can bind so
you're probably going to see a higher
quantitation of these ones this is what
we're likely seeing
and then for the avid assay it's
specifically a receptor binding domain
so that's much smaller yellow section of
the spike protein
and then um
finally for neutralizing antibody i just
wanted to go over that
again the neutralizing antibodies are
going to be the antibodies that are
going to stop the interaction between
the spike protein and that ace2 receptor
and so
typically these are done by plaque
reduction neutralization
assays
they're high sensitivity and specificity
but they have limited throughput
and they're highly specialized but in
our case we actually used a new gen
script assay which gives a quantitative
function of neutralized antibodies
and that's how we
have the yellow bars here
so if we look at this again this is a
zoom in of what we saw for the high
high positive antibodies
serum is red here all the way across the
board the dried blood spots do fall a
little bit in blue but we're seeing an
increased decrease of the architect igg
rbd and gray as well as the gen script
for the neutralizing antibodies which
makes sense because there's probably
fewer neutralizing antibodies than total
antibodies in the serum
finally we looked at
low and mid positives this is contrived
blood dried blood spots versus serum and
you can see that the gen script has
fairly good neutralizing antibodies in
the yellow
consistent with the serum which is in
the red for the dioceran
and if we compare that to the blue which
is the dry blood spot so there's
definitely a decrease in what you're
seeing for the dried blood spots but
it's still above what you're seeing with
the avid rbd
so if we pull out
just the diaphragm testing you can see
that the serum is consistently at the
high mark with slight decreases of the
dried blood spots for those high samples
but again they're all above 1300 so
they're very very high and
basically 100 concordant in a
categorical agreement
and again here is their same for the
serum in red and the
dried blood spots in blue you can really
see that there is a decrease in what
you're seeing for the dried blood spots
but if you look at even the very low
positive samples these are still
concordant even though they have very
low values
so again showing that dry blood spots
can still pick up even those low values
when you have contrived specimens
so we also looked at the whole blood uh
dread blood spots so here we had 10
volunteers all the volunteers were
triple vaccinated and two of them
actually had coca-19 infection after
vaccination
and our age range was 23 to 60 years old
so this is what we found
um samples one and seven were triple
vaccinated and had breakthrough
infections so they have higher levels of
antibodies um not unexpectedly and some
of the volunteers who only had
vaccination and no infection
um
four and five have much lower antibody
levels than what we would anticipate
but even five who had um by the serum
which in here is is blue
uh very low levels of antibodies we were
still able to pick that up by dried
blood spot
which is really good for the assay
so overall dried blood soap was 100
concordant with serum samples on the dsr
and liaison and the quantitative value
was lower on the dried blood spot
compared to serum um in the contrived
samples so in high positive samples we
saw less of a decrease they were
basically 93 percent of high positives
in the mid range we saw about 50
decrease and low positives we thought 37
but if you're looking for just a
qualitative yes no for antibodies it's
still 100 concordant with what we're
seeing in serum
and then finally for the quantitative
value for dried blood spots in the whole
blood samples we saw an average decrease
of about 55 percent
so for practical uses of dried blood
spots i think this is really helpful for
remote settings where phlebotomy access
is difficult
um and this is a large portion of our
province and we have this problem for
basically every test to try to get
people access to care
i really think that this might be a very
interesting thing for research studies
looking at cereal prevalence because you
would be able to access a lot larger
population base
and maybe get a better idea of what the
true prevalence for antibodies is
uh you may want to include a conversion
factor if you're assessing a
quantitative value because we know that
these are
trending to be about 55 percent of the
total volume value for serum compared to
dried blood spot
but i really think that you can use
these to understand the prevalence in
the population and that's maybe where
the power of these ones lie
so with that i will
thank you for listening to the
presentation and i will take any
questions
thank you dr charlton for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is
did the alberta cerro survey data you
presented make any impact to public
health measures
so yes it did actually so i'm just going
to go back to that slide quickly to ha
to show you again
um so
this is kind of the snapshot of the
first two waves and so
with our sero survey data because we
were able to give this essentially in
real time to public health they were
able to use this to
help them identify when boosters should
be given to the population and when we
start started to see our antibodies
declining that's when they started to
push booster vaccination and so i think
that this has definitely helped public
health measures from that respect
and we continue to do this data because
it is helpful for public health to
understand what's happening in our local
population
thank you
next question
can you comment on the quality and
variability of collected dbs in testing
so yes i think that was that's one of a
really important question that um the
at-home collection is really
thought to be
inferior maybe as a first pass than a
healthcare provided collection
but in fact that's kind of the opposite
that's what's what has been found is
because a lot of people who are doing
at-home collections are very
engaged and they read the instructions
very well and you get
very good sampling now that's not to say
that all of them are
exactly perfect but you do get a very
good sampling and at least equivalent to
what you would get if a healthcare
worker were to do the sampling for you
so i think that dried blood spots at
home still are a really good
possibility especially when you think
about the access to care issues or
barriers to care for a lot of
individuals
thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
because there is a drop in quantitation
for dbs
how do you see dbs working in research
and clinical settings
uh thank you for that question i i think
that um
the drop that we see
in the whole blood cell impulse
especially is
um probably more like what you would see
in a real life scenario and so i think
it is possible that you would be able to
come up with a conversion factor
of a dried blood spot quantitative level
compared to a serum level and if you
were able to have that quantitation
level and it might not be
a linear quantitation it might be
something similar to what we were seeing
that you know a high positive has about
93 of what you see in serum whereas a
lower positive you're only seeing about
37 or so i think that might be similar
to what we would see with the whole
blood but i think if you could have that
conversion factor you could very easily
transition into something that you would
have seen with a phlebotomy draw and a
serum sample
thank you dr charlton do you have any
final comments for our audience
no i just wanted to say thank you again
for letting me present i really
appreciate the opportunity and thank you
thank you again dr charlton for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor diasoren for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye
you